Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Now moves from the chapter regarding
intentions and sincerity
into the second chapter which is the
chapter regarding repentance.
for
[Silence]
he says that our scholars mention
that repentance is an obligation
that is binding
with regards to every sin that a person
commits
whether major sins or minor sins.
Repentance is an obligation
from every sin major or minor.
He says, "And if a person's
sin that he is repenting from
is a sin that is between himself and
Allah
and has
nothing to do or doesn't involve the
rights of another human being
then there are three conditions for the
repentance being accepted. If we were to
say what is repentance, it's kind of
saying what is Islam?
Islam has conditions. It has pillars. It
has obligations.
Likewise, we are to say what is
repentance? Repentance has conditions.
It has pillars. It has obligations etc.
Every act of worship in Islam is built
this way. And so repentance
is one of the greatest acts of worship
there is.
And repentance
is one of the reasons why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala created the human
being. So that the human being
would build his relationship with Allah
based on forgiveness
based on
continuously striving for the
forgiveness of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that that forgiveness or that that mercy
that he obtains from Allah is not felt
to the slave as if it is earned
because none of us earns paradise.
None of us earns his way into paradise
rather we enter paradise by the
forgiveness of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala.
Now when noah here says that if a
particular sin
is between Allah and his servant and
does not involve the rights of another
human being. What does that mean? Sins
are always between Allah and his
servant.
However, there are sins which a person
commits that involve another person.
for instance, theft. Theft is a sin
that is between a servant and Allah.
However, it also involves the rights of
another human being.
murder for instance for instance
these are sins which involve the rights
of another human being.
When we
look at a sin that does not involve the
right of another human being,
such as Zena for instance,
or for instance,
the consumption of alcohol or any of
these sins that do not involve any other
people, do not involve anyone else or
the rights of someone else that have
been depleted as a result.
And so if a person commits a sin and in
committing this sin they have not
depleted the rights of another human
being. It is only between them and Allah
then there are three conditions.
Number one.
So these conditions, a good way to
remember them
is that these conditions
are with respect to past, present, and
future because repentance is an act of
worship and it is a state of being,
right? It's a position that the heart is
in with regards and with respect to the
past to the present and with the future.
And so when we look at any any sin a
person is repenting from any sin
that sin has a past has a present and
has a future in a person's life.
Therefore, repentance is from is the
combination of three conditions.
Number one is that the person cease
this act immediately. That they stop
doing it.
Person cannot repent while they're still
doing it. This isn't repentance.
So
with regards to this present they stop
immediately.
The second condition is that a person is
mournful.
They have regret. They are regretful for
doing the sin. This is with respect to
the past
the future.
And with regards to the future that the
person have the unwavering
sentiment and that the person have the
unwavering
will and intention to never go back
to doing that sin again. Now this is
repentance and noah is not speaking
about
if a person goes back to doing it again.
That's not what we're speaking about
now. We're speaking about there's a sin
and a person wants to repent from it.
How do they repent from this sin? Well,
that repentance is a combination of
three things. Number one, they regret
what has passed. They regret doing it.
Number two, they stop doing it
immediately. Number three, they intend
to never do it again. A person may say,
"Well, what if they end up doing it
again?" If they end up doing it again,
then they repent again. And it doesn't
invalidate their previous repentance.
However, there is no way
to short circuit
or jerryrig
or beat the system. It doesn't exist.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala looks into the
hearts. A person cannot think to himself
and say, "Well, you know what about if I
just I repent right now, but then I
could do it again. and if I do it again
to it doesn't work that way because if
that were a person's intention then they
missed one of those three conditions
namely the third condition which is the
the true will and intention to never go
back to doing that sin again. And a
person when repenting, one of the
biggest deterrents from repentance
is a person's
attachment to that sin that they are
committing, their attachment to it. What
does that mean? Their attachment to it.
When a person commits a sin
and then they make it into a habit,
their heart becomes attached to this
particular sin.
They want to do it again and again. It
starts to become part of their norm. It
starts to make up what we refer to in
English as your comfort zone.
And disturbing or disrupting that is
traumatic for the person. And I say the
word dramatic, I'm using it very
loosely. It is an extremely overused
term.
But what we mean is that when a person
constantly does something,
it becomes their norm. And disrupting
that norm,
the person starts to go through a type
of withdrawal.
And so
if a person wishes to repent from
something, it doesn't mean that when
they repent suddenly they're cured from
that from that addiction. Whether that's
a physical addiction or a psychological
addiction or what have you. It doesn't
mean that person will repent and they
will be completely forgiven by Allah,
but they still want to do it, but
they're still plagued by it. they still
backtrack. And one of the biggest
deterrents
from repentance is a person's
fear of having to leave something off
forever. I'm never going to be able to
do this again. Whatever could possibly
take this thing's place.
And this is why repentance
is a worship. And what are all acts of
worship predicated on? Allah tells us
and he teaches us this lesson in the
first chapter of the Quran. He says,
"You alone do we worship and you alone
do we beseech in aid."
So we seek aid in Allah in all acts of
worship.
When a person repents, one of the
biggest deterrents from repentance is
the fear of the future. And one of the
biggest things that causes a person to
backtrack and go back on their
repentance is a lack of upon Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala. They feel they
have to do it on their own. That doesn't
exist.
That does not exist. A person will never
succeed on his own. A person has to
place his trust in Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
Alhamdulillah.